I've been noticing a kind of I don't
know if it's like a trend or uh just a
thing that's happened recently in
Hollywood uh because I don't know if
they've they've obviously done this
before but I think so much like AAA
movies now like the Mario movie like you
know the new Flash movie it plays off so
much Nostalgia hype because a lot of
people getting hype about this new uh
this new Flash movie because Michael
Keaton returns as Batman and everyone's
like oh my God it's the goat it's the OG
Batman who actually cares about that
other than like die hard fans I'm sure a
lot of people care about that because a
lot of people might keep Michael Keaton
was like their first Batman yeah like
that's like our age group that wouldn't
that wouldn't really appeal to us yeah
right like we're like [__] Christian
Bale Fanboys yeah that's that's what
Batman we grew up with right yeah yeah
yeah
um so uh actually for me it was George
Clooney
the greatest [__] Batman film with Al
Schwarzenegger yeah because I'm just
wondering yeah
because like let's be honest we enjoyed
the Mario movie right but if like you
just said if we had no yeah if I if you
had no Nostalgia about Mario it would
have been a [__] move yeah no nobody
would have given the [__] about it the
same thing with like the Sonic movie as
well you know I've watched the Sonic
movie and the only reason I enjoyed the
Sonic movies was because I am familiar
with the Sonic franchise not because I
actually think that they are good movies
when I went to the theater to watch
Sonic there was actually kids there when
I went to watch the Mario one there was
no kids there
yeah
says a lot about Society yeah
I I think actually the Sonic movie was a
better movie for kids
uh Mario movie if if you didn't play
enough Mario I just feel like you just
wouldn't get off the movie I mean kids
there's so much [__] it's so vibrant
and light that I'm sure 10 year old me
would eat that [__] up even if I didn't
know what Mario was but I mean I don't
know I think though with the Sonic stuff
like it's because like I think Sonic has
done a better job of I guess franchising
themselves more to a younger audience
because like they have like the sonic
boom animation right like the TV show
that they have you ever watched that I
have some I've seen like a compilation
of like Knuckles saying [__] up [__]
it's so funny it's like how is this a
kid's show their artists go hard on this
yeah yeah but I think because they've
like you know capitalized on that
whereas Mario hasn't really done
anything like that
um yeah I think that's where it's like
oh there's a [__] Sonic movie well
I've seen it on as cartoons on you know
Sunday morning TV so I'll take my kids
to go watch it kind of thing whereas
with Mario it's like well I [__]
played this game 30 years ago and uh I
want to see what it looks like today
yeah exactly how long do you think it
it's going to take before they make a
Pokemon movie that's not like detective
Pikachu like a straight up this is a
Pokemon movie like it because I'm I'm
calling it now like uh because the Mario
movie did really [__] one box
officers there must be someone in
Nintendo that's having this conversation
right now if not like two years ago if
they just made black and white into a
movie it'd be such a good movie yes but
they would never because that's like the
most mature Pokemon plot we ever had and
it's about like is enslaving Pokemon
okay and should we do it it's not gonna
be that it's gonna what if they just
remade the first movie but like with the
[__] budget of today's stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean like you know
Pokemon already has animated movies
anyway so it wouldn't be too much of a
stretch to change that into live action
so it would it would take actually less
effort than doing the [__] mask Chris
Pratt to voice Ash right
to play him live
live Chris Pratt has a 14 year old Ash
or however old Ash is now but he would
get cashed in there
ashes like 10
no we should just know it would just
turn into a bunch of references it would
be like whoa pass me the jelly filled
donut whoa don't go there don't go to
Lavender Town play the poker flute whoa
Snorlax she said no way whoa you know
what I mean like I I want to die so
let's not let's not do that yeah yeah
but that'll work for the Mario movies
and I'll watch it if they bring it in
Pokemon
like and I hate that I like it
works on me I'm a [__] idiot suck
though well uh I can't watch Oppenheimer
in Japan yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I mean
Connor having dinner and I was like oh
I'm so excited for Oppenheimer to come
out and he's like I don't think he's
getting released in Japan I was like why
isn't it game released in Japan
why do you think guys
what do you think the story about
Oppenheimer is not being released
freaking Japan Christopher Nolan it's uh
let's uh like realistically I I mean it
is a shame because it's not like it's
like glorifying it in any capacity no no
it's supposed to be like a tragedy right
well I mean it's
a horrific event yeah and I think
there's a way that you I'm still I'm
sure knowing Christopher Nolan he'll
have a take on it that is interesting
and yeah I don't know yeah I could I
could also understand you just being
like let's just not let's I get it I get
both sides it was Pearl Harbor every
release in Japan
I mean I've watched I've watched movies
about World War II in Japanese theaters
like they clear yeah they play them from
both perspectives they're not I think I
think it might have been yeah
if Pearl Harbor was released in Japan
then I have I have hope for Oppenheimer
I mean it makes more sense to release
Pearl Harbor in Japan than Oppenheimer
right like I mean uh yeah I mean because
the Japanese will be like yeah I think
I think it's a very different
perspective
I don't know if you've seen Paul
I think it's a very different
perspective sort of scoreboard
you're the only one you're the only one
in this table who can say that it's like
a sports game guys
oh my God we got the advantages well you
know they they what's that I watched
another movie recently that came out
that was like of the perspective of one
of the pilots and who it was like a
goated pilot who were just killed I
guess Japanese people and stuff I said I
watched that in the cinemas yeah yeah
it's weird oh they get released go on
Cal you gonna oh no
the thing is is that I mean nuclear
staff in Japan is still a contentious
topic to this day yeah especially you
know after 2011 as well even more so uh
you know so I I mean I can understand it
and also I imagine it's more of a
decision on the American side as opposed
to the Japanese side the American side
might be like yeah let's let's not yeah
I mean yeah from from the Googling like
that I did it hasn't been confirmed that
it's like not getting released there
just hasn't been a release date yet so
maybe yeah like John Wick we knew we
were getting [__] it was coming out in
September yeah I mean it was weird that
the Mario movie was released here weeks
after everyone else I'm like yeah how
does that make sense like this is a
Japanese IP and we're getting it after
everyone else that just goes to show how
slow people work in Japan
say we are in the IP and we still gotta
land we couldn't even get the Mario
movie God I I do want to know what the
inner workings behind that is because I
watched it just with subtitles I'm like
why did this take a month I'm feeling
like I feel like this could have been
done on Fiverr in an hour
I don't think I just needed to be that
dude I don't know man I don't think
you've ever done translation work yeah
because like I I watched it with
subtitles as well and I was you know
every now and then I was kind of like
reading the Japanese subtitles because a
lot of the jokes are very American yeah
yeah like very pun related like yeah
like idiom related and so I was I was
watching some of the subtitles for it as
they were telling some of these like
jokes and I'm just like I don't think
Japanese people are gonna find this
funny yeah like legitimately like I was
reading the subtitles I'm like where's
the joke
because it's like really hard to you
know [__] be like oh you know [__]
Mario's mushroom is like really big
it's like [__] dick and balls jokes
you know when like I remember like one
of the lines like Bowser was like you
know love really makes me come out of my
shell and I'm just like all right first
of all shut the [__] up and second of
all I was reading that in the subtitles
I'm like they just like complete they
just gave up on that point oh yeah that
was just like we don't know how to
translate I think she can't really
translate right yeah exactly I did
notice that how much did uh the audience
laugh in your viewing of the Mario movie
uh there was only there was only another
couple an hour oh certainly me like
giggling away at like Jack Black yeah
pretty much I was watching the Mario
movie and like for 90 of it everyone was
[__] like dead silence Japan that's
Japan yeah and then like it's it's like
every time that I thought there was
clearly like a joke there like the one
thing that uh like you know
stands out to me the most is you know as
someone like you know kind of like edits
jokes in my own videos there's a certain
like pacing and a rhythm when a joke's
being told like when when you have
really epic music and then you cut to
silence like when with with the scene of
like the penguin starring [__] like
everyone was like dead silent and then
they were just like randomly laugh at
like real like like when there was like
zero jokes there like like when Mario
was just like running uh doing like the
Montage people just started laughing I
was like where's the joke this is the
hero's moment yeah what what's happened
to the Japanese theater experience yeah
I go like every week and I swear to God
I I you you just if you just have like a
random number generator at any point
odds are like that's the only time
they'll laugh like you just stop it and
they're like all right it's frame or
nothing's happening and they're like
yeah I watched um I watched uh the movie
Air it's probably like how Air Jordans
was made oh okay I was just like [__]
I'm just gonna watch it and see how it
is yeah so what yeah one thing I found
funny is that do you know you know uh
Christopher uh uh Chris Tucker right
from like rush hour yeah he was doing
you know his Chris tucker-esque acting
oh he's like super fast talking yeah
slang and I was like I was like trying
to read the subtitles and I was like
there's no way they can translate what
he's saying like like in a way that is
like cohesive in Japanese yeah because
he's just like making a bunch of really
like you know Chris tuckerisms yeah and
I was like damn this is gonna be so
weird for a Japanese person to see this
translated it must just be like like
translating like sterile English or
something
um that was good that was fine movie
really weird though they never showed
Michael Jordan once but they had like it
was very weird it's too expensive well
yeah they uh it was a weird man I don't
know if anyone else would watch this
movie I'm just like why don't they just
show Michael Michael Jordan yeah I mean
I mean I like I like going to flip that
around I sometimes get that feeling when
I'm watching like an anime and I'm like
I feel like I'm getting half of the
experience here because uh they sound
like uh they you know for something
let's say like monogatry or like other
anime where it's just like I feel like
there is more to this dialogue than I
can comprehend in the subtitles right
now but there is no possible way I can
actually like take it in fully take it
in without just you know becoming better
in Japanese
yeah that's why like at least with like
monogatari I've always said it was a
[__] miracle that there's even a fan
base for it outside of Japan because
it's like it's already such a niche fan
base in Japan let alone trying to
translate that type of writing into
English that still holds on to its
meaning and makes it just as good yeah
it's like I I always wonder I'm like who
who are these fans of monogatari that
like watched these episodes and was like
yes I gleamed enough meaning out of this
for me to like it oh well uh I I think
that just comes down to the writing was
just so good that even if you didn't
glean everything you still got like a
good enough idea to be like oh this is
this is still good yeah and maybe just
like a [__] ton of translators notes
back in the day if we remember that
stuff I think the biggest hardest part
was for me sometimes when there are
sometimes there there's so much dialogue
that's speaking so fast and I'm like I I
am breaking the limit trying to keep up
with these subtitles the first episode
of to Tommy gallon oh my God that's just
like machine gun like like it goes like
like that was wrong Rap God oh yeah that
[__] thing
so like I don't know how easy it is to
like read like translate from English to
Japanese and be able to like read the
subtitles as fast because some some
actors have certain mannerisms uh and uh
way of speaking that I'm like I don't
think the slang exists in Japanese man
and you're always gonna get something
Lost in Translation as well